welcome back well we can now see some
live pictures of sir richard branson
who's just launched
his first virgin galactic fully crewed
flight to the edges of space it was
delayed by around an hour because of the
weather
so exciting
45 seconds well greg milam is there at
the launch site
and here he is we can bring him in now
to give us some more details on what's
going on here
we're counting down as you can hear uh
counting down to this launch let's
listen into mission control
five three
two one release release release
clean release ignition
good rocket motor burn
there's mach 1 trimming now
trim complete unity is pointed directly
up and heading to space things are
looking great we are 25 seconds into the
burn
now approaching mach 2.
we can see from the ground 30 seconds
mach 2
everything's looking really good and
stable to an altitude of 56 miles above
the earth
40 seconds
45 seconds
50 seconds approaching mach 3.
i think we should stay on this as long
as we're seeing it though because you
know this is
folks we are headed to spain
we want those windows pointed down
towards the earth to maximize that
incredible
view
so feather is coming up now and the
pilots are also enabling
the rcs or reaction control system which
is what they'll use to control the
attitude of the vehicle or outside the
atmosphere
and as we've said you know
all right feather is all the way up we
are at about 250
000 feet now and climbing as soon as we
cross the boundary to space we'll hear a
word from our founder
sir richard branson
richard branson welcome to space unity
for 17 years
so it doesn't sound like we're receiving
the audio over the broadcast but i know
richard is saying something
inspirational as he always does
fortunately we have a lot of cameras uh
recording things on board today
and we'll be sure to capture his magical
words and share them with the world when
they're available
we reached apogee 282 thousand feet
remember the day remember where you are
and remember who you shared this with
and remember the name virgin galactic
because today
space is virgin territory so there we
are
uh sir richard branson has reached space
that dream he's had since watching the
moon
1969 as a teenager has been realized
today
they were hoping that we would hear some
words from uh sir richard branson once
he
reached that landmark where they seem to
be having some technical problems maybe
not surprisingly 56
travel and of course for sir richard
branson and virgin galactic having had
that moment
and uh those moments of them floating in
space that again
they're trying to bring pictures of that
to us uh it will begin its descent after
those few minutes of weightlessness and
we'll be
on the ground again in in ten minutes or
so we can speak to emily
uh professor of the director of the
astra campus at the university of york
and
seeing
[Music]
a lot of people know and expect the
boost portion of the flight to be
loud and thrilling but what's
interesting is re-entry is also very
similar
as supersonic air is flowing over the
vehicle in the feathered configuration
shock waves form on top of the cabin
which are audible to those inside
and for those of you on site watching on
the ground you should be able to hear a
double sonic boom as spaceship unity
once again i think we lost you just for
a second there
what what what what is your feeling
watching this and
what do you what do you think they must
be feeling we keep seeing some broken up
pictures of them
floating weightless in inside that
spacecraft what would they be feeling
right now
well we just keep using this word
exciting don't we everything's exciting
but this is exciting beyond anything
that
you've ever experienced before going up
into space going through that rocket
burn where you're
you're in a little craft you're pointed
straight up out of the
earth you're going in many times the
speed of sound
you might be experiencing kind of three
times the force of gravity that you
would experience on the earth just to
get up there
and then you have these magical minutes
of weightlessness
where kind of what's happening is your
whole craft is falling towards the earth
at exactly the same rate you are so
there's no extra force there you're just
sort of floating around i think we got
just a few seconds of clips of uh the um
what
i guess they're now astronauts they've
passed the the 80 kilometer astronomical
line so they're
uh these astronauts floating in space
just
hd camera data down to the ground yeah
we can see that um altitude on this on
the right hand side of the screen we can
see how quickly they're descending
back of course back into the earth's
atmosphere and then
uh that will uh that craft will land
like a traditional aircraft it will
glide back down to the runway from which
it took off
and and i guess for richard branson for
those on board bearing in mind they were
doing the job what this is like as an
experienced
that's the test did they achieve what
they wanted to achieve as remarkable as
this all
right now well if they're seeing any of
these views that we're seeing for now
uh from the feed then they they must
have just been astounded by how
beautiful the earth is and that black
sky the curved surface of the earth
the desert below
you were talking earlier about some of
the experiments aside from this being a
remarkable
marketing moment for virgin galactic
there's a lot of science involved in
what they're trying to do on this craft
as well
and all of us will get to hear that
absolutely so huge amounts of technology
go into the development of building
these systems and i think that's
important to acknowledge because we want
to build bigger and better and safer
systems to take not just tourists but
also
scientists into space to perform what we
need to uh we're talking about going to
the moon
and the not so distant future we need to
be able to do that safely and
comfortably
then of course we've got all the
experiments that we want to do to
understand
space to understand what it's like to be
in microgravity where you've experienced
almost no gravitational force
i mean even the the very outlandish
ideas of can we
build systems that would help us survive
say a journey through space to mars
these are ideas that we really are
testing to see if they're feasible
i think we just heard it you may be
saying a slightly delayed picture there
we just heard the sonic boom
richard from that crowd and we're about
to hear from
uh as well i think we should listen in
uh to what they might be hearing here on
the ground
no they still seem to be having some
technical problems reaching reaching
those um
uh on board uh as they uh come back down
32 000 feet coming back down uh to land
on the runway here and be reunited with
their families after that
uh extraordinary experience and i guess
dr brusdan if you if you're still there
what we're seeing is so different isn't
it we see the inside of that cap
much more like an aircraft than the
rockets and the capsules we've been used
before the spaceship absolutely this is
space travel done
in style this is not what you might have
seen when you seen an astronaut go
on a launch up to the international
space station where it's a very cramped
very tiny little capsule that we use to
transport people to the space station
that's done purely to conserve as much
fuel remember the space station is a
little bit further more than what these
um people are going up to today so we're
talking about
maybe you've been up to 83 84 kilometers
today
we're going up to 400 kilometers to get
to the international space station
and that requires huge amounts of fuel
every every square centimeter of space
is so valuable
when you're taking people up to the
international space station that you
just get no
no creature comforts so to see the
interior of this
um unity spacecraft which is so
different it looks like
i guess first class of a international
jet
that's going around maybe the most
luxurious
private jet
hard work together
i'm looking down at our beautiful
spaceport
i said congratulations to everybody for
uh for creating such a beautiful
beautiful place
congratulations all our wonderful team
which i think like this for 17 years
that's
hard hard work to get at this point
all right so i'm still happy we could
catch you overturned who is who is
he is now officially uh an astronaut
which is the big difference from from
when he woke up this morning
having reached that landmark that is
defined by uh
more than 50 miles above the earth's
surface and they are now
back on their way down uh you should see
the altitude droppings
that took them out about an hour or so
ago this journey has now gone back out
to the runway so clearly expecting them
to be back on
the ground shortly and and then we're
expecting to hear at a news conference
from sir richard branson
a little later but you can only imagine
the uh the jubilation
and dr president it seems from the
united states
that everything went um but talk us
through again this this issue
around whether they actually went to
space or not this this debate that
exists
about where they were
above spaceport folks turning our
attention right above the sky
nasa and the u.s air force defines space
slightly differently
to how we are also difficult to find it
in international conventions
so the earth's atmosphere is continuous
it just goes um
up into space it gets more and more
rarefied the higher you go so
sort of choosing a line where the
atmosphere stops is really hard because
it's a very
um diverse thing but they have we have
to make a decision of where the
where does earth atmosphere finish and
where this kind of space outer space
begin
nasa have defined this as being at the
50 mile point above the surface of the
earth so that's when they give their
astronaut wings to anybody who exceeds
that um so that's sitting at about 80
kilometers
but the definition that's been used by
the international
community when we set up things like
space treaties
that's called the carmen line and that's
defined at the 100 kilometers
so 20 kilometers more doesn't sound like
a lot but it is
a little bit higher mothership eve right
there above space
how about a round of applause for the
mothership and we're expecting that um
that craft to uh to land from that
journey whatever you um whatever you
designate speaks space or not certainly
virgin galactic
taking that nasa definition and
believing that all of those aboard
are astronauts some of them already have
been on on test flights before but
um a number of them hadn't including
richard branson of course astronaut
zero zero one as he described himself uh
when he arrived at spaceport uh this
morning
uh
this journey richard branson's been on
from as he talks about watching that
moon landing in
in 1969 to i think talking to buzz
aldrin in the 90s about
whether it would be possible to use a
plane type crash
uh for this and then the launch of
virgin galactic back in 2004
the loss of one of those craft and a
pilot of course did you ever think
that it would be possible that we would
see this day actually happening and
watching these pictures as we are now
it does feel like we're living a little
bit in the future doesn't it it's so
it's so great
there's something about us i think
that's really really deeply ingrained to
be excited about exploration
and when you think about going back to
1969 with apollo missions and even
more recently the 50th anniversary of
that it just stirs these amazing
emotions of
excitement and exploration so to see
that happen
from in the course of a lifetime to go
from being completely
every human that's ever existed walking
on the surface of the earth
to now putting whereas maybe a few
hundred people have been into space
uh most of them astronauts although i
think very very soon there's going to be
a lot of tourists that are going to join
that group
it's a it's an amazing advancement of
technology that we've come
through and i think we should i guess
globally be proud that we've managed to
do such an amazing accomplishment
would you like to go all right we have
three landing gear absolutely wouldn't
it be wouldn't it be a stunning view if
nothing else are going to be landing on
runway 3-4
today what do you think the feelings
must be for someone who likes a richard
branson
who's who's not a scientist of course
tuning in
clearly excuse me he's invested in this
over many years
for example what must it be like uh for
a civilian if you like to make a journey
like this
we are just about a thousand feet i
think whether you're a civilian or
whether you're a scientist there's
a there's an amount of when you get to
this point of being up above the earth
you're looking back down
you're seeing a perspective that very
very few have seen
and for richard branson that's a mixed
feeling i guess that's also coming in
about
his drive for very very so long i mean
he thought
this first flight was going to happen in
2007. here we are 15 years later
um success so must be incredibly
fulfilling then just i think just take
that step back and look at our planet
and realize
this is a planet this is our space that
we have to live
and we we talk a lot about how we have
to look after it and it's a perspective
that
astronauts i think have very very keenly
nose gear touchdown yeah
dr president sorry to interrupt just to
say they are now safely down
on the ground richard banson and his
crew have returned safely you saw the
chase playing alongside them but they
are now back on the
back on the runway that uh they they
took off from
a couple of hours ago and there you go
there's the reaction from
the the virgin galactic founder himself
a successful mission
to those of us watching from outside
everyone returning safely
and a remarkable moment for him of
course in that journey that dr bruslin
was just talking about
that he has been on to taking himself
into space
uh and as he says really unleashing now
the possibility
of this being a new era in space travel
for many more people to follow him
uh into space so the spaceship unity
continuing its journey up the runway
uh there will be safety checks and all
kinds of
things to happen before they are
reunited with their families and then
there will be a news conference as i
said
where we'll hear from uh richard branson
uh a little later
this evening um about six o'clock we're
expecting that news conference
will take place and we'll hear from him
again but look at that image there
uh spaceship unity back on the ground
here in new mexico
now officially